most people are not super wealthy but we
all have an idea of what it might be
like to be a wealthy person we watch
them on TV we follow them on Instagram
we read their blogs and autobiographies
unfortunately that awareness of how the
other half lives doesn't happen much in
the other direction though many of us
have probably described ourselves as
broke or poor at one point or another
very few have an understanding of what
real poverty feels like and it's not
just a matter of having less money once
you get below a certain threshold a
whole new set of rules apply that
actually make day-to-day life more
expensive if you've never struggled with
real poverty you might not be aware of
the many hidden costs and financial
traps that conspire to keep poor people
poor it's very hard to make your way
through modern life without access to
basic financial services like checking
accounts ATMs and personal checks but
the less money you have the more these
things will cost you
that's because banks make their profits
by accruing interest on your money so if
your account balance is too low usually
under $1,500 they won't consider you a
profitable client anymore and they'll
make you pay for their basic services in
the form of a monthly fee and heaven
help you if you go below zero
each overdraft incurs a charge of about
$35 and many banks will deliberately
reorder your transactions for the day
from biggest to smallest to drive you
into the red more quickly and rack up as
many overdraft fee's as possible if a
bank is willing to extend you credit at
all the terms will be much less
favorable than for someone with a rosier
financial history you'll pay more money
in interest of it and any late payments
means more penalties
even cash can be more expensive if you
don't have much of it if you withdraw
$100 from an out-of-network ATM that $3
fee equates to a 3% service charge but
if you can only afford to take out 20
bucks at a time you're essentially
paying a 15 percent charge to access
your own money taken together this means
that a poor person might end up paying
hundreds or thousands of dollars a year
for services that wealthier people
virtually enjoy for free it's no wonder
then that a lot of low-income people
avoid banks altogether but even that
comes at a steep price cashing a
paycheck without a bank account money
buying a money order to pay your
electric bill costs money and if that
bill is due in just a couple days well
you can either get hit with a late fee
or FedEx it an extra expense that
someone with a debit card and an
internet connection never has to worry
about if you think that dealing with
credit card debt is bad thank your lucky
stars you've never dealt with a payday
or car title lender these businesses are
often the only recourse for people
without credit cards and their interest
rates reach upwards of eight hundred
percent annually not only does it cost
more to borrow and spend money but what
you spend it on is often more expensive
if you have to feed a family on a tight
budget buying in bulk at a supermarket
is usually the best option but not one
available to many poor people even if
they had the cash on hand by weeks worth
of food in one trip how is someone who
depends on public transportation
supposed to get at home on their lap on
the bus big food retailers want enough
purchasing power to offer low prices are
notorious for avoiding poor
neighborhoods and people who live in
these so-called
food deserts often lack the mobility to
cruise around town bargain hunting
instead they're stuck with local
convenience and corner stores whose
prices are much higher or they rely on
fast food which can seem cheap in
comparison but is actually more
expensive than cooking at home to say
nothing of the long-term health risks
rent can also be more expensive most
landlords require a security deposit
between five hundred and half thousand
dollars to move in an impossible sum for
people barely scraping by and in that
case your only option other than
business might be a low-end extended
stay motel which typically don't require
deposits but cost way more than an
apartment in the long run and they often
lack amenities like kitchen appliances
and laundry that save apartment Fuller's
time and money they say time is money
and the less money you have the more
time you have to spend on everyday tasks
waiting at the bus stop waiting at the
laundromat waiting at overcrowded
clinics and public offices this leaves
much less free time to take care of
one's family pick up extra work or
strategize a way out of poverty it gets
worse inflation the general increase in
prices tends to hit things like food gas
and rent the hardest the lower your
income the greater percentage of it goes
to these costs so a poor person will see
their year-over-year expenses go up at a
higher rate than a wealthy person all
these pressures take a toll on one
psyche that only makes things worse
imagine having to constantly make tough
decisions about where to spend your last
few dollars pay the water bill or buy
food for dinner put gas in the car or
see the doctor this relentless burning
of mental energy leads to a
deterioration in the quality of one's
judgement a phenomenon psychologists
call decision fatigue it's why someone
might visit a payday lender when they
know it's a bad idea they're so
exhausted that the settle for a quick
fix even if it will lead to more
problems down the road
closely related to decision fatigue is
this a scarcity trap which is our
tendency to fixate on the resources that
we have the least Oh to the point that
we lose sight of the big picture running
low on diapers for instance can create a
feeling of panic that compels a poor
mother to bite six months worth of
Huggies only to realize afterwards that
she didn't set aside enough money for
rent some might think that poor people
just need to work harder and spend
smarter while it's true that improving
your financial situation requires these
things it also requires having at least
a little bit of extra cash to move
around and access to decent spending
options
you can't choose where you shop where
you live or where you bank you become a
captive customer to predatory businesses
if you don't have any extra money to
save our Investor budget you can't make
financial plan and when are you supposed
to think about tomorrow when you're
constantly putting out today's fires
next time you describe yourself as broke
remember that having just a little bit
of wiggle room is infinitely better than
having none at all it can make all the
difference if you're trying to improve
your financial situation so if you do
have that local room be thankful and
don't waste it and that's our two cents
missing one payment can quickly spiral
into a pit of debt has this ever
happened to you and were you able to
escape it share your story in the
comments
[Music]